da Cunha's da Cunha's cubanos Cuban
heels otherwise known as man heels meals
helping short man out since the Spanish
flamenco from whence they came and they
could be the real reason the North
Korean leader Kim Jong hoon has been
m.i.a he hasn't been spotted since
September 3rd and was strangely absent
from a parliamentary session on the 25th
apparently the world can't resist
knowing where the chubby man in charge
of this totalitarian state is at every
waking moment he is quite entertaining
canna despot gets him alone time damn
but according to a South Korean
newspaper who's been getting surgery on
his ankles after hurting them back in
July while wearing the use case of
Kanye's the South 31 year old has the
same taste in heels as his father they
give him a leg up the kind Dennis Rodman
gives to one's foreign policy but since
assuming office in 2011 the Kings powers
have come with the king's appetites
now the international press is
exchanging your dictator so fat jokes
but why pick on own he's not the first
a-lister nor politician who wanted a
boost to their career Tom Cruise Bono
and Mick Jagger have all put a little
lift in their step get a load of the one
on Sarkozy just shy of Carla Nicky boy
even louis xiv was known for his shoe
fetish the monarch was only 5 foot for
inbreeding in modern times Cuban heels
have been fashionable ever since Vito
boots this must-have for the petite ohm
isn't going anywhere anytime soon much
like Kim jong-suk Onassis nuclear
ambitions maybe life is just too short
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation
available in your app store now